you know dude so that gymnastic
[ __ ] that you do i watch some videos on
your instagram oh and
you like to see a dude your size just do
a standing still backflip is pretty
[ __ ] mind-blowing
yeah it is that [ __ ] bro how did you get
so good at that
i've been doing that since i was like
five really well not the
not the cheerleading but just bliss so
is it it lives yeah
so it's it's actual cheerleading mm-hmm
okay competitive cheerleading
competitive cheerleading so i started
cheerleading when i was like 15.
but um yeah like prior to that i just
loved
martial art films man yeah you know and
so
i'd see that [ __ ] and uh i'd see them
doing all the flips and i was like i
could [ __ ] do that yeah right what
little kid doesn't want to be able to
yeah
i think i could [ __ ] do this you know
yeah and then um
and then yeah straight up i just like
[ __ ] started trying it outside
and then um you know i just got better
and better at it
and then um you know i had a crush on
this girl
that's how it all starts um every good
movie yeah every good movie
yeah there's a crush on the girl you
know i was outside of her house with a
[ __ ] boom boxing
you know so funny i've never even seen
that movie i just know that scene
has to know that one part what is that
was that the notebook
no it's a [ __ ] it's an old movie i
forget the name of it yeah i don't know
classic though yeah it's like a classic
movie but um yeah what made you want to
get into that into
competitive cheerleading well i didn't
want to get into it oh yeah
she just yeah she was in there yeah
she was she was uh and she saw me do the
flips and [ __ ] so she asked me to join
and i was like [ __ ] yeah let's go
there's this dude on tick-tock i forget
i don't remember what his name is but
uh he's got like a probably an
eight-year-old daughter
oh yeah yeah have you seen him and
they'll do it stay in their living room
and like she'll be standing on his hand
and he'll
flip her up she's like 10 flips back on
his hands yeah
that [ __ ] is wild it was wild you have
to like
eat [ __ ] i'm sure a lot of times
practicing that you know what
i don't think i ate [ __ ] that crazy
really yeah
you know like how do you get to that i
mean like what i mean
like how do you i mean [ __ ] but like not
you know
not real yeah yeah because there's so
much like with progressions
yeah and like you learn how to fall
you know so like because you you start
to have a body awareness
the people that eat [ __ ] have no [ __ ]
body awareness
they don't know how to fall they don't
know what the [ __ ] they're doing yeah i
don't know how to fall
you know um yeah sometimes it's out of
your control
yeah you know where you you know it's
like oh i can't do [ __ ] about this let's
just fall
but um you know a lot of times
you know it's just it's [ __ ] i don't
know there's there's progressions to it
right you know i know your limit yeah
you know your limit and you know like
what you're capable of and like
you know there's so many drills that
progress you to like the next
skill so you never you know out of your
comfort zone with it because you know
you've done these steps and so it's like
oh now i'm able to
fully do it you know that's how it
that's how it is
you know yeah no it just seems it seems
hard to like wrap my mind around how you
pro
like incrementally progress to that
level
yeah yeah in someone's hand
you know i mean i get it like
skateboarding you can jump into a foam
pit you know what i mean you can launch
a huge rant practice something into a
phone pit but
to be able to do something like
literally standing on somebody's hand
with no nothing below you yeah i guess
they practice above
mats and [ __ ] for a long time yeah yeah
you practice yeah you practice on on
that [ __ ] a lot before you take it to
the video
but uh yeah i mean yeah i just worked my
ass off
you know i was the same way with with
skateboarding
you know i i loved skateboarding and all
i did was just
you know i don't know it wasn't even
like i wanted to work my ass off it's
just
i just liked it mm-hmm like if it's like
everywhere
yeah if if i do something that i really
like
maybe do it every day all day oh man i i
lock into it
yeah and it's because it's just like
it's it's like fun to me like
you know you know thinking about like
yeah hard work yeah i work hard just
naturally
you know um but i think
you know i mean yeah you look at some
guys like you know like you look at
like a kobe bryant or lebron james or
you know you look at these guys that are
just like
these freak of athletes but you know
their work ethic
yeah is [ __ ] insane yeah it's great
right you know like it's like yeah they
could they could still suck they have
the [ __ ]
ability to suck but they're dialed you
know i know i know they're
you know you know those guys have like
a little bit of help you know what i
mean like you know
with natural physiques um but
yeah at the same time they could still
suck at it right you know what i mean
they can still like they're still
capable yeah their mind has to be a
hundred percent
full yeah it's like okay i got this gift
right what do i do with it you know what
i mean like
just [ __ ] let it be a gift or take
the gift above and beyond
right you know what i mean are you an
nba fan uh
i will once i quit cheer i started
watching basketball okay
so you watched just you watched this
year's finals uh i actually didn't see
this year's uh
finals okay cause i don't [ __ ] my
[ __ ] tv
did they want me to pay extra for this
yeah it apparently had like the lowest
viewership of all time
yeah i saw that that's pretty weird yeah
it is pretty weird
i mean there's a lot to play in account
man i mean who knows where people
the bubble the virus who knows but i
mean i was i was [ __ ] locked into it
just like i was everywhere yeah
i know it is weird man like it's just a
weird time
for everybody like no one knows
the whole world is weird man like no one
[ __ ]
knows the correct answer but everyone
acts like they [ __ ] do yeah yeah
that's the funny thing about a lot of
[ __ ]
and just watching people literally like
they got the answer
yeah yeah they go do you [ __ ] know
you [ __ ] no
right
[ __ ] that like some of my friends like
say to me
i go how did you come up with that yeah
like i [ __ ] know you
yeah i know what you do daily right now
you're a doctor or scientist and [ __ ]
what did you watch
dude yeah it's it's it's literally the
weirdest [ __ ] well they're saying this
they're saying this no one [ __ ] knows
yeah no no no one [ __ ] has the
accurate answer
you know because everywhere is [ __ ]
different you know what i mean
who who knows like i mean
like that's one like i'm just such a
geek of learning
right you know i don't i don't walk
around
like i i would hate to walk around
acting like i know
right spitting that's not the truth
exactly
you know you know what i mean like so
dumb yeah i don't like that [ __ ] i don't
like walking around
like i [ __ ] like oh i know this yeah
right
you know what i mean i don't [ __ ]
know i don't [ __ ] know yeah
you always got to assume that the person
you're talking to knows something you
don't right yeah
exactly and i like i learned that from
uh i'm a big henry rollins geek
you know um and i don't know who henry
rollins is
all right i'll see you guys later
[Laughter]
who is he rolling it was in bands movies
yeah he was in black flag that's why i
do this
oh you're just the first person i've
ever heard
he's uh he does a lot of spoken word
he's like a
you know human rights activist now he
was in bands and but like
he's one of those dudes he just um he's
just
he wants to be tuned in he wants to
learn okay he wants to educate himself
uh like he doesn't walk around like he
knows
right everything he just wants to learn
and i those are the people like
that i look up to and appreciate because
you know
he doesn't talk like he's capped off he
talks
he talks as if he's like wanting to know
more those are the people like i [ __ ]
with
you know i mean yeah so i've gotten rid
of all my friends
[Laughter]
yo for real man but yeah like you i mean
how annoying is it when you get in a
room with somebody and they're just
they're just like preaching to you just
like telling you how it is about it oh
dude i'm the worst yeah i'm like
she's like this [ __ ] guy yeah you
know it's it's the most annoying [ __ ]
that's like
if there's one thing that really bugs me
it's that right
you know what i mean i go how do you
like how am i supposed to trust you
right like i
argue with people like that yeah i yeah
i think about a lot i mean
everything's [ __ ] you know wild in
this world right
you know yeah naturally it's gonna
[ __ ] happen it's gonna be wild
you know there's there's so there's so
much uh difference in the world but
what i think you know a lot of us don't
realize you know i travel a lot and go
a lot of us are [ __ ] same more than
we actually think
you know it's so it's it's it's like
people want to explain more of something
else than themselves
that's the thing that [ __ ] you know
like boggles my mind you know people
want to tell you about this or tell you
about another person
or tell you how you are but couldn't
even explain themselves
that's the wildest [ __ ] to me like
that's the [ __ ] i think about on the
regular
i read a lot of [ __ ] stoicism books
not books like well yeah yeah [ __ ] with
stoicism a lot yeah
you know it's just an intriguing i think
you know i've just seen the best result
from it
you know by uh you know following it
because
it's a lot of it is like being in tune
with you who you are
and like what i've come to realize with
you know
jumping into that world is that like
yeah i don't
you know necessarily go after
people or like anyone else or i don't
make things about anyone else
but myself you know what i mean like one
of the biggest situations you know
i grew up i grew up with an abusive
stepfather you know
and i'm one of those rare cases where
you know it doesn't i don't have like
any ill will
towards him or i don't want to like go
after him
you know what i mean i don't want to go
right this guy [ __ ] wronged me
for 17 years you know let me
now now i need you know justice
from this right you know what i mean i
don't want that you know
foreign